the ability recorder allows you to
create a recorder you have an iframe and
you embed that iframe on your website
and you can ask a series of questions
they can answer it through audio through
video and you can capture that
information it will automatically
structure the the response for you then
do the transcription then the analysis
and then you can pile that into a folder
and do an anal an analysis welcome to 20
minute leaders just sit back relax and
learn from the leaders of today it's a
journey each one is different unique
inspiring let's get started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures Jay Ventures
Riverside Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
is that you have such an interesting
background unfortunately we don't have
time to dive too deep into it but for my
from a real interesting hockey career
the psychedelics too Ai and uh
specifically a language today with speak
Ai and looking at how do we extract
insights from language which really is
the foundation of everything that we do
the whole way we communicate in our
world is through language and and it's
kind of mind-blowing how little we still
today leverage information from the
language we have around us whether it be
from an organizational perspective a
personal perspective and so I'm excited
to talk to you about the different use
cases the different opportunities and
how you're thinking through them and
running around startups pki so thank you
very much for being here of course and
you know I'm just uh glad to be on here
and fascinated with how you're going
about this happy to answer anything I
can hopefully give some insights along
the way wonderful well let's start 20
000 feet in the air
insights from language tell me a little
bit about your your understanding today
as to where we're at and what are the
different opportunities we have with in
regards to extracting insights from
language in general yeah yeah I think so
you've sort of touched on a couple
important pieces of it then there's a
lot of excitement right now about sort
of large language models and sort of
generation of language but it seems
today that a lot of the Practical use
cases applied in business are coming
from more of a classification extraction
summarization kind of layer and that's
been really exciting to me I I sort of
went on this journey for a couple
reasons one of them was personal it was
wanted to be a hip-hop artist and I fell
in love with language I fell in love
with conversation I just thought
communication and the fact that we can
do this with you know we can make these
the sort of shapes with our mouths this
can happen and we can understand each
other such a beautiful brilliant thing
and what I realized as I started to
digitize some of those conversations I
was doing both audio and video summaries
and recordings but then I was also using
system everyone's very familiar with
there often is Evernote documenting all
my sort of thoughts journals and I was
like why is there no sort of system that
holistically combines audio video and
text together and then builds like why
doesn't it resurface insights that are
coming from that if you're documenting
so much into these systems there's
something valuable in there and
something that should be sort of
extracted automatically that maybe you
couldn't identify as a person but is
very capable for machines to do it so I
actually fell on this journey from a
very personal
interest of how can we do this and in my
own work I was doing sort of marketing
and I was at a marketing agency so what
I was Finding I was doing a lot of data
visualization of specifically marketing
data a lot of it was Google search sort
of keywords Search terms and I found
something really interesting which was
like a slight variation to a keyword or
search term could
um change someone signing up someone
buying something or it could just be
something that was someone was just
navigating around looking for
information it wasn't going to lead into
anything and I found sort of this
combination of language marketing data
and then the visualization of that
information and because it was such
large data sets that if you sort of
piece that all together right you could
display some insights to your client and
they would have this amazing
breakthrough and that breakthrough would
often be around their business but it
would also maybe even just change their
entire mind of how to operate sort of
personally within that business and
that's what really excited me so
um you know from that perspective how
can we
how can we just process this exponential
increase of language data that's where
I'm really interested in and have seen
sort of several use cases verticals in
Industries emerge and sort of adopt this
technology at a high speed over the last
few years so so let's even even before
we dive into speaking what are you doing
there let's talk a little bit about
these vertical use cases and how some of
these yeah yeah how some of these use
cases can come into play in our daily
lives to either make a positive impact
or organizations or make a positive
impact on the end consumers that are
then being a sort of consumers of these
organizations products
yeah I think you know a big separation
that I've seen and it creates a lot of
nuances and it is like conversation
versus written uh text and conversation
I mean is such a crucial part of our
Lives both personally and professionally
and then we start to see the emergence
of systems that are now driving that so
when I think of this space I think of
transcription being one layer of this
and then a lot of the times the analysis
being put on that and then you can go
into specific verticals around that so I
would say to sort of this idea of like
vertical Focus versus horizontal Focus
companies one of the one that comes to
mind probably familiar with otter AI
sort of this horizontal transcription
company that has been adopted which has
become almost this digital
record-keeping note-taking system for
speech for conversations really powerful
really exciting the challenge is if you
start to then segment that person who is
in these conversations into a special
specific use case that system might not
be as powerful enough so then you've
seen the emergence of saying I'm a
salesperson I want to do that so then
you see the gong you see the chorus AI
you see these companies companies that
are once you go past this horizontal
layer of value which in that case is
just accurate capture of data good
transcription you need to go into the
second layer I think which is can we
tailor this to a specific use case in
industry and can we use data from that
business to optimize the insights that
are coming out of it so if gong looks at
100 calls obviously it's nice to see 50
calls that went well 50 calls that
didn't well didn't go well take that CRM
data push it through and then make the
insights much more useful compared to
maybe a horizontal conversation where
you're sort of throwing insights and
hoping that some of them hit hoping that
some of them stick so that's what I'm
really interested in is this sort of
verticalization we see sales you see
customer services see health care but I
think they're even going more Niche than
that where it's within customer service
it's customer user research you're going
we're just going to continue to see what
people think is a large industry get
more and more Niche and more and more
sort of deep into each one of those
niches right and so I think you're
touching on this greater Trend that we
were seeing from an academic perspective
which is you know these these larger
these large language models are supposed
to have these few shutter one shot cases
or their ability to respond versus these
fine-tuned mechanisms where how do we
take these these Foundation models and
then fine-tune them to these specific
use cases like you're mentioning
um yourself and so if we're looking at
some specific interesting use cases
let's say in in healthcare or customer
service whatever you choose how how do
you see language dramatically impacting
the way that an organization runs a
hospital or runs a customer success team
how is language going to be an impactful
part here
because I think one of the more
practical adopted cases and there's
challenges with it because of compliance
and security but is Healthcare and just
the you know the time so I think
actually you've maybe invested I think
ELO's Health he's seen deep scribe I
think generally there is just too much
information and work that is put on
practitioners who have really important
things to do and so there's this heavy
burden and technology has the ability to
automate or at least expedite that
process for them so how can you take
five hours of manual documentation how
can you take that down to one hour how
can you take that down to 15 minutes and
the amount that that frees up for a
practitioner maybe professionally to see
more patients to do better work or also
just spend time in their lives with
friends and family I think those are
huge uh you know positive impact on on
those businesses on how those
organizations are operating and again
there's challenges with it accuracy
there's all this complexity of it but
generally I think there actually is a
real world application today that at
least allows you to speed up the time it
would take from a manual process right
and and you're mentioning obviously a
lot of these more sensitive ideas about
regulation and compliance and how do we
then bring not just NLP but technology
in general into these worlds and and so
diving deeper into speak Ai and your
work you you came in with this sort of
understanding of this motivation saying
listen there's this blue ocean there's
all these opportunities all these
verticals that and all these different
use cases that we can do
what was your thesis with speak AI
oh so it's fascinating especially when
you build it into a uh you know like I
love the sort of viewpoint that you have
from a thesis perspective
um what I saw from more from outside of
a thesis what I saw was problems that
were happening concurrently and a lot of
the clients that I was working without
my marketing agency and I needed a
system to help solve those problems and
and so I thought that holistically
combining audio video and text analysis
together was a valuable so that was one
thesis was that we actually needed to
stack speech to text and natural
language processing together and at the
time that wasn't when they sort of first
started this that wasn't as uh obvious
of a thesis or a thought it was like
those things were sort of running in
parallel but then just transcription
alone would create another you know one
transcribing something just creates
another set of problems it solves one it
digitize things but then all of a sudden
you have an overwhelming amount of
information Ten Thousand Words how do
you process that how do you understand
that what can you do with that
information now that it's actually
transcribed and then on the natural
language processing beside it was like a
lot of that technology wasn't advancing
but there was challenges with applying
that to speech data and just audio in
general so the transcription layer was
needed and that sort of put in a way
that was the thesis that I had was
combine it I didn't necessarily have the
deepest vertical in mind except that I
was already working with marketing and
content creation and I saw a lot of
specific use cases specific to that that
I wanted to explore and I felt that I
could transition my clients into that
software for more of a service model
which is every agency owner's dream and
that's where some of this sort of
started and so the speak AI product well
what what products are you building
there that are answering to these ideas
yeah so speak AI is sort of you know
luckily I've been able to fulfill some
of that uh Vision ambition so we've
built software it has apis that run in
parallel so companies hook into that but
is this idea of you know you and I take
this conversation right now we can
stream it in or dump it in everything is
transcribed but and that transcript
becomes interactive searchable and
navigatable but there's also this
insights layer that's put on so we're
doing an identity recognition extraction
of entities brands people locations etc
etc we're also running some sentiment
analysis on it and we're also
summarizing it what the layer that we
find really fascinating I think where we
sort of gone with ours is we're not just
trying to analyze a file individually or
transcribe a file individually we're
actually aggregating it into a dashboard
that is sort of updating in real time
and what we were finding was like Google
data Studio or Tableau or some of these
systems had a really tough time sort of
natively handling audio especially audio
and video data to produce insights from
it so
um where we're spending a lot of our
time is with I would say just to make
this list more concrete it's like a
market research firm market research
firm comes to us and they say hey we're
looking for to identify a trending
flavor across all the food podcasts and
all the food influencers on Tick Tock
and Tick Tock and YouTube he would dump
they would dump that into our system and
we would basically automatically reveal
that information for them and that's the
part that gets really exciting and what
we've found is a lot of people come in
with hey I just want to transcribe
something and we can iteratively extract
these insights and find this information
on them so when they dump a big data set
in all of a sudden it becomes this
exploratory breakthrough Journey that
they didn't realize that they were even
going to have and so that's where we
find a lot of value Creation with our
product and get really excited about and
so we look at just to wrap this up as
sort of the three pillars capture
analyze and share and those all work in
Harmony and if you can't for example
share the insights in a nice intuitive
way that other people can see and derive
value from that's then then the whole
chain of value is lost so we're spending
actually a lot of time on the sharing
part and how can you visualize this
information and share it in ways that
are valuable to a client or someone
who's maybe non-technical trying to get
insights from this big data set
so you see we're mentioning the the this
idea of non-technical user that is using
this how relevant for them is sort of
this understanding of language models
versus their understanding of what
insights there they they may be able to
extract from language because a lot of
it may seem also common sense that we
have all these crazy data sets or
potentially yes conversation so how how
do you sort of treat your your end
customers here how much what what
knowledge do you expect them to have or
do they need to have in order to take
part and and sort of these language
models and their real use cases into our
world
that I mean that's definitely been a a
Learning lesson along the way and so a
lot of people will actually come with
the base use case of just transcribing
something for us sure and they don't
even know sort of what they're about to
jump into with their application in some
ways we've had this really wonderful
breakthrough moment that leads them to
create more value in the app although
times are like why are you giving us all
these insights we don't care sure like
you're actually getting in the way of a
use case that we just want to fulfill
simply
um but I think what
the pandemic sort of the digitization of
meetings and all this stuff has created
a more General understanding for people
to maybe not understand a solution to
the problem but understand the problem
which was I was just in 25 say meetings
this week or and there was 2 000 YouTube
videos I'm supposed to research I can't
handle all this myself I need some sort
of tool generally what people come to us
with is hey I've got x amount of videos
or audio files or even just big text
documents I'm looking to find X Y set
whatever it is and we're help either our
systems helping them do it automatically
or what we've actually did given them is
like the modular building blocks to
extract that information without needing
to code I think that's where we found
some sort of differentiation or some
value which is
um you know maybe it's a more technical
person leading up but they need to
enable a non-technical team they don't
care about the language the tech stack
on the back they don't care about how
these models work like maybe it comes
back to this market research firm is
like all I care is about we find the
most trending flavors across all these
videos and we help we help them find
that and that's all that really matters
to them and so if we're looking at this
sort of base layer which really does
sound like a fundamental use case that
that all all these companies need right
which is the other data extraction
summarization and named entities
transcriptions
Etc this is a pretty tough market right
I mean you have uh for sure these are
technologies that have been obviously
built on over the over recent years how
do you how do you positions speak AI to
be a differentiating player within this
Market where you've mentioned a lot of
the other counterpart players that have
been around for a while that are also
giving a lot of these Services how are
you thinking strategically about
creating this differentiation for you
yeah I think one we do look at this sort
of no code low code
um sort of mindset like enabling
non-technical people and I think they're
generally very thankful for what we've
enabled them to do because what we
typically find is there's this weird gap
between I would say consumer
applications maybe again some I'll use
the example even though I love them as a
company otter which is doing some
amazing stuff and then now enabling more
NLP but isn't maybe necessarily letting
them customize the extraction of
insights to the level that they want
versus then hooking into you know AWS or
Microsoft Azure or leveraging you know
libraries from hugging face Etc there's
a whole other sort of technical
expertise that's required to make that
next sort of stage or get to Market
happen we'll sort of sit in this nice
middle spot where you don't have to have
the big development team the Big
Marketing budget and our goal is to get
you to extraction of the insights that
are valuable to you as quickly as
possible without the need for a big
development team or data scientist and
there is actually a surprisingly large
Market there that is looking to solve
this and so from a go to market
perspective are you mainly positioning
yourself selling to these no code teams
that are less technical or is it may or
is it the more technical leaders that
are coming and saying wow I can leverage
this tool I understand sort of how how
it's used and what benchmarks it meets
and now I can now I can bring it to my
less technical team to use it yeah which
of these is more relevant for you from a
go to market perspective it's
interesting we so we have a really nice
sort of organic channel that flows into
search and we get a lot of the literally
no code people who are trying to do that
and then a lot of times they'll then um
throw our system to the more technical
team member to validate that it's uh you
know sufficient yeah so if is this a
suspicious solution and then generally
the part where we found people want to
back off or don't want to build is like
sort of this interactive navigation
search layer of media it's like you know
hooking into a couple apis and pulling
the data out and getting it in Json
format is wonderful but to build the
whole like it's a it was frustratingly
annoying to make the system that we made
and I think developers if they're
technical enough and depending on their
team maybe they want to take that
Journey on but a lot of times they don't
and they just want their team to be able
to have a solution that is providing
what they want and they'll they'll give
them like the thumbs up and say go ahead
with this and then we'll work with them
to customize anything if they need it
and so what what are these teams really
searching for you mentioned that a lot
of these are coming organically through
through searching for Solutions so what
what what Solutions or what problems do
they usually search for so that they
come to speak AI is it mainly a Google
search for transcription of sales calls
or or is there something or do you find
them different things so we've built out
yeah so we've sort of stacked modular
sort of landing pages out and it could
be anything from like how to find Brands
and data sets from a volume perspective
of search transcription is still the
biggest driver of just like initial
looking I have a problem like people
think this Market is completely
saturated and this Market is done it's
not true like people are for the first
time ever just trying to figure out how
to solve this problem so that's
hilarious it's not hilarious to me but
it's sort of funny that we just see this
endless flow coming through that
specific use case but more just as an
example we've built sort of um
Solutions within our system that then
serve the customers that sort of Stack
into the rest of this workflow for just
as an example we have this little system
called the embeddable recorder the
embeddable recorder allows you to create
a recorder uh you have an iframe and you
embed that iframe on your website and
you can ask a series of questions they
can answer it through audio through
video and you can capture that
information it will automatically
structure the the response for you then
do the transcription then the analysis
and then you can pile that into a folder
and do an anal analysis so like if
you're trying to get customers like I'll
just give you an example from an actual
customer you know like the government of
New Zealand has to do public
consultations on uh like a bill that
they're going to pass and they want to
collect audio and video responses
they'll use this and then organize it
into this specific Bill and analyze the
responses to that so that is fascinating
like uh and that's a huge driver of our
business we didn't know it at the time
but it opens up an entire layer and then
the last part I'll add to that is a lot
of the systems don't have pre-built or
play nicely with sort of an integration
layer so one of our most successful
things is a zappy integration which is I
want this recording and the transcript I
want to send it to an air table row
automatically every time it comes in
that our system enables that and they go
ahead and do that so we've seen sort of
dual sides the capture side you know and
then I would say the analysis side so
try side that those three colors capture
analyze and then the share part all
really providing sort of traction and
growth for our business this capturing
is a really interesting idea and I'm
thinking through all these massive
surveys that we're sending out we're
asking people to sit down and to to
choose multiple choice questions and you
know part of that is that we need this
to be ultra structured data right why we
have surveys in the first place very few
times we're allowing them to be
unstructured you're basically saying
let's rethink or we have the potential
to rethink a lot of these structured
surveys and turn them into a more
friendly you know human facing
interaction where we can let people
speak freely and then extract these key
ideas maybe it's not as structured and
it's not as clean as traditional service
but but it's but it opens up a new
medium for people to be able to interact
with content and to share ideas that
before was just unusable because we had
no way of doing anything with this data
right yeah that's I think we see a lot
of people who are trying to sort of take
qualitative information and turn it into
quantitative information we believe
that's a huge opportunity and the tools
are just sort of emerging now to make
that possible and I think we will see
more of a trend towards people
collecting unstructured feedback and
just you know uh you love those
structured sort of surveys and responses
but there's this idea of people just
free-flowing and telling you what they
think and the amount of meaningful
information that can come from that I
think is is very exciting that makes
sense
how's the research integrated into
um you know for you to be able to
leverage a lot of these a lot of these
models and a lot of these solutions to
your customers how are you looking at
natural language as sort of a vehicle of
transformation right it's an emerging
technology that over the over the last
five years has been breaking benchmarks
time time after time every week we
essentially see new benchmarks being
broken and new models being put out
there so how are you positioning
yourself at this intersection between
research and usability for the End
customer well where are you at yeah yeah
I think it really does depend sort of
the team size the technical Talent where
you are in a business I think the way
that you uh approach this problem and
for us because we've sort of been lean
self-funded it took some non-diluted
funding here in Canada our Focus has
been to sometimes inherit the advances
the advances that are being made and
then customize them to the use cases
that our customers specifically do and I
know that I've seen
a couple of you know good friends in
this space who have made massive
Investments for example in building
speech recognitions from from scratch
and now the maintenance the cost to just
keep those sufficient in advancing with
some of the other systems is pretty
enormous we you know we chose just
because of the business that we built to
try to
um use some third-party services and all
of them have flaws all them like in an
ideal world you're all building your own
systems to your perfect thing but
there's a lot of problems along the way
and then we again sort of customize it
so we've stacked sort of some
third-party services and we've built a
lot of analysis capabilities ourselves
what we're finding more of our research
and development is this final
interaction layer that needs to happen
so how do you format this data for
display or how do you take an internal
data set and flip that into a publicly
shareable data set in an intuitive way
so that Technical and non-technical
people can derive value from it so it's
sort of this cross section between the
back end and the front end creating
value where we've spent a lot of our
time and from our conversations with
people who have focus more on the the
back end these are problems that they're
really struggling or trying to figure
out how to solve so I look forward to
the advancements that are made but it's
a very messy thing to try to figure out
how to sort through and find you know
thousands and thousands of hours of
audio to get the response or the
information that you truly care about
right I think that a lot of the what
you're getting at is sort of this and I
think it's a pretty coherent agreement
amongst a lot of these people that are
pushing the boundaries on the
researchers that a lot of these models
and solutions are going to be
commoditized from a technological
perspective right so a lot of these
today these large language models they
cost uh dozens of thousands of dollars a
year to run a single instance of not to
mention the millions to train them and
so it sounds like what you're saying is
we're taking a proactive approach saying
we're not necessarily going to be in The
Cutting Edge scene of the research we're
not trying to push the boundaries but
but but we find a gap in being able to
leverage some existing technologies that
are already quite impressive and how do
we productize them so that the long tail
of customers the end users that are
either technical or non-technical
they'll have access to them in ways that
are already good enough to be pretty
transformative to their own businesses
and like you're mentioning
transcriptions have been around for for
quite some time companies like verbit
and Otter they've been around for quite
a few years now but you're saying that
this is still an unsolved problem not
from a technological perspective but
from a productization perspective yeah
for sure yeah and I I think those
companies will continue to advance that
no no none of these companies like
Amazon and Google and Microsoft they're
not building these services to what am I
trying to say like they're going to come
on they're going to commoditize and
productize these so there's still a risk
in that approach that you're taking and
like we've saw even just as an example
like Google Docs released um sort of
like an automatic summarization layer I
think a few months ago and there was
entire companies and industries built
around summarization and in a way Google
uh you know took a pretty big chunk out
of that without with just a simple
single release into the the
infrastructure that they have so I think
either you know like you said it's a
very competitive market I think where
we're trying to do is stay as close to
we can as we can to the customer and
find these like really interesting sort
of edge cases where it's just not solved
maybe it's not a big enough priority or
it's just so unique or Niche that it
just doesn't seem that there's a a
driving enough solution forward where we
often end up in head-to-head battles
against companies that are maybe more
capitalized maybe seem more impressive
on the outside but they just seem to sit
with us because we care we want to solve
the problem and we've ended up building
our system in this sort of modular way
that allows them to get there
so until now my my understanding was
that you are taking a more generalized
Approach at a lot of these use cases you
were talking about the capturing the and
then the the analyzing and then the
delivering of this information so it
sounds like a more generalized approach
but but you're also mentioning the more
Niche use cases so what's the
differentiation from your end as to how
speak AI is is targeting a lot of these
use cases which will make people stick
with speak AI even if these larger
companies come in and and let's say Zoom
now provides these automatic
transcription summarization search
analysis how are you how are you getting
those customers so just as an example
there's an awesome there's a really
talented personalized nutrition research
firm that we look with and work with and
so they've sort of custom built their
account on speak to specifically operate
around personalized nutrition so just an
example a category could be ketosis and
now all of a sudden all the insights are
tailored to them and so a bit of a big
project whatever say there trying to
scrape you know thousands of Amazon but
looking for certain terms basically
across Amazon uh Amazon store reviews
app reviews Twitter et cetera Etc and
we're like there are listening tools out
there there are ways to do you could
push together a bunch of tools to do
this why don't literally offer them some
solutions that were possible and they
said it doesn't work for us because the
analysis isn't the analysis in their
system isn't tailored to the
personalized nutrition work that we're
doing so they would rather actually use
our announced our system and then pull
all that information into ours compared
to a bunch of different services so I
think that's where we're starting to see
is once you build up basically say
you're talking about ketosis and then um
analyzing a big data set we'll reckon
we're finding words that are related to
that and we're allowing you to
iteratively build the analysis we're
saying hey here we recommend you
including this one in the analysis et
cetera et cetera that builds up to have
a point where it's sort of hard to leave
that system and you're not going to get
that data back in a structure that
another company would give you and
that's where we're finding True Value
and then returnability and sort of
continued data dumps into our systems
where it builds up value over time so I
think that's what we get excited about
most
and you mentioned before something
really interesting about
the sort of uncovering insights that a
person may not be aware that exists when
they were first starting to use the
platform so you're mentioning that
there's these more fundamental use cases
like transcription that somebody may
come to speak AI for but then all of a
sudden they're getting exposed to all
these different insights that they're
providing that they weren't necessarily
expecting before you mentioned the
negative part of it was saying that
they're saying well I just wanted
transcription why are you giving me all
this all this other information yet yet
I think part of what I'm hearing is that
the thesis says that this extra
information is actually pretty valuable
and and just because they think the only
transcription maybe they don't
understand how they can be leveraged
leveraging all this other information
from a product perspective what are you
doing to help them sort of get there and
how are you privatizing this in a way
that that these end customers can can
learn on the Fly what are the different
opportunities that natural language can
provide them
yeah and it's a beautiful question one
that we've continued to sort of develop
and grow with I I would say that what
you're saying this Insight art is
essential like it's not just like a a
nice at the start even it was more of a
nice add-on like hey this is really cool
but now with the amount of information
that is out there it has become just an
um a very important part of any business
and I think you're actually missing out
on opportunities if you're not taking
advantage of it so generally
um I mean there's a couple goals for us
here is always to make the insights more
valuable you know what I'll just stop on
this point for a second the word
insights is a tough word itself like
it's become this catch-all industry term
uh and uh you know I well just as an
example we used to think that entities
and named named entity recognition was
an Insight what we found out was that is
not enough just say hey we found a brand
it doesn't really mean anything in
context you know what I mean there's no
context there so then you need to ask
how can you stack brand across multiple
audio files just an example and then
pair that with sentiment and then find
related words to that brand then all of
a sudden you're starting to stack the
value or what's possible or like what
you could realize through that
information so we're just continuing to
productize the display of this and so
it's so it doesn't become just sort of
this entity without context that's one
one way that we're looking at it I think
the other part is like we do do
transcription and Analysis and there's
an individual analysis but our goal is
to guide people to what we basically
call the explore page or the insights
page which is almost like an aggregated
dashboard if you're familiar with Google
analytics familiar with you it's almost
like that except instead of seeing um
you know how many people are watching
your videos you're actually starting to
see trending keywords or sending
trending phrases
Etc et cetera and generally what we've
found has been if we can get someone to
that explore insights page at the right
moment where there's something that's
valuable it's a little bit of a trigger
whether it's this little
transformational moment that they have
or they realize why we built all this
sometimes seemingly unnecessary stuff on
top of this layer
um that they're doing so I think that's
another big part that we're doing is
just continually trying to D
make it less Technical and guide them to
the areas where a breakthrough is
possible and once you have a
breakthrough more breakthroughs will
start to come very cool Tyler what are
you most excited about as you're working
through these Technologies and you're
building speak Ai and you're watching
all these different vertical use cases
and you mentioned before briefly how how
enamored you were you were by some of
these use cases that have evolved like
with the New Zealand government and and
so what are you what are you most
excited about what you're doing right
now
yeah so ah man uh I love you know just
from just a little bit of understanding
of you you're very driven by curiosity
and passion and I think that takes you a
lot of places sometimes takes you on but
the exact right trajectory you want
sometimes you can get a little off the
beaten path uh exploring things but a
couple things I I am really fascinated
by large language models I do think
there is ways that um sort of
classification and stuff are really
interesting from a business case but I'm
fascinated with more generative models
so I'm playing around with dally right
now I just got early access to that and
it's to me it's pretty mind-blowing
what's possible what I look forward to
is when we convert that into from image
to video so entire videos are built with
large language models I really am
excited for that stuff to start
happening and then more generally I I
think a lot of the analysis that we're
doing is like sort of retroactive
analysis across the entire industry
there's a lot of live transcription and
captioning and stuff but um I think
there's a lot more that we can do in
real time with sort of the analysis of
what's being said how it's being said
and sort of helping guide conversations
helping you get the information Nation
you need in the moment and actually
augment conversations to make them more
impactful and positive and my last part
I think is just um
and you know in my other life which is
my current life is like you know there's
sort of this hippie spiritual part of me
so I love going to events I love going
to you know Burning Man and these events
really sort of merge technology and art
and I really think there's a future
where we augment our own environment
with our voice
um to create sort of these personalized
environments that help us operate at
Peak productivity Peak Performance Peak
Wellness that stuff really excites me so
I see a cross-section of media and art
and wellness and understanding of
ourselves all combining here over the
next few years that makes me pretty
pretty pumped sometimes I love it and
Tyler thank you so much for spending
this time with me I know how busy you
are and uh and uh I I really appreciate
your insights both on the the the the
research oriented piece of it but then
also the productization and how you're
realizing this long tail of use cases
where you know we yeah we have all these
this great NLP technology and then these
and these great models but we're still
so far behind it sounds like Yeah from a
an industry perspective on the different
things that we can fundamentally do with
with with text and speech and it sounds
that companies that are able to
productize a lot of these fundamental
business needs like transcription
capturing data and then creating these
basic insights you're then going to be
able to use the commoditized models to
be able to provide richer and better
experiences for your existing customers
and by creating this trust with your
brand that they know that they that
you're creating products that are
dedicated to their use cases and their
verticals and then you can continue to
be ahead of the game and continue to
provide them with with really
interesting uh interesting words so
thank you very very much Taylor I really
appreciate your time and your energy and
best of luck with speak AI thank you sir
foreign